Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 219 to David. Now, this voicemail
is part of a bigger thing that happened over the
weekend. There was this Trump rally in Anchorage,
Alaska. I covered the rally. We had a nice
audience of 15, 16,000 live viewers on a random
Saturday night. Nice audience. Lots of people
who don't like me and who don't like leftism.
Stumbled across my live stream and they felt
furious in an entitled way where they. They
spent the last two days writing to me saying, Why
are you interrupting the great President Trump
with your commentary? One guy even said, I should
leave the country or something. And here's another
caller who really didn't like the fact that I
covered the Trump rally the way I wanted to cover
it, as if you couldn't just find another stream.
Speaker 4: You know, it's painful to watch your
show because I'm trying to watch the Trump
rally and all you're doing is talking over,
right, making snide comments, wanting
to shut the fuck up and let us listen.
Speaker 1: Okay. Watch it somewhere else. Watch
it somewhere else. You don't have to listen to me.
You don't have to watch my stream. I'm doing
my commentary and the level of entitlement
and people saying I shouldn't be speaking
over the president. Just let him tell his
lies unchallenged. I'll do it the way I want to do
it. And even, by the way, maybe not surprisingly,
xenophobic and anti-Semitic responses to
the fact that I had the audacity to speak
over the great orange anointed one. Give me a
break, guys. I'll do the show the way I want to
do the show. You can watch somewhere else if you
don't like it. We have a fantastic bonus show for
you today. Joe Biden says he is considering
declaring a health emergency over abortion
access. And we're going to talk about what that
means and what might be the result of doing that.
A pregnant woman in Texas was pulled over in the
carpool lane and she made the argument. And I
believe it's a good argument. Listen. Based on
the law, I have a person in my belly right now.
And so, therefore, I should be able to use
the carpool lane. And of course, this is the
kind of silliest example of the absurdity of the
right wing personhood arguments I've said before.
Those are if it's a person, if the fetus
is a person, it should have citizenship.
If the fetus is a person, it should be entitled
to child support, etc., and they don't want to
do any of that. But here's another just glaring
example of this absurdity. Why can't you be in
the carpool lane if that's a person in the womb?
So we will talk about that. And then number three,
there is a new law in Arizona seeking to limit the
recording of interactions with police. We're going
to talk about the First Amendment legal community
saying you can't do that. That's actually,
you know, for all the times that the right loves
to say that. What about my First Amendment?
What about my free speech? They don't
know what the hell they're talking about.
We have an actual First Amendment issue here,
which we will discuss on the bonus show. Sign
up at Joint PAC Mint.com. Get instant
access to the bonus show. And of course,
you can use the coupon code. Big voting 22. To
get yourselves a discount. We're here all week
unless anything changes. And look forward to
seeing you tomorrow or on the bonus show and here.